[Music]
good
morning gamers what a beautiful day huh
don't you just love it
wow i do love my house now i think it
looks great
i'm very happy with it look at this it's
safe
have a little opening there for me and
you're going to ride out
like the storm yes i did a little
off-camera work but
what are you gonna do sue me huh we're
gonna do hire a
harvard phd i can't yeah
oh yeah oh yeah this is gonna be
confusing if you didn't watch the live
stream
which i understand it was like five
hours four hours we all know the
incident
drowned in the kiddie pool i didn't
think it was possible
but apparently they can okay then
another
a ride that's in there i think he's in
there unless he
so i'm just going to assume the new is
the old
i realized how the sound and how insane
this minecraft let's play is
whatever we're playing it hardcore and
you know that workout would say
speaking off-camera work you guys are
gonna like this all right i need to do a
little bit of
cooking better check out my uh
furnace house a lot of people don't
actually know this you can have a
furnace as a mailbox
you're gonna furnace as a whole line a
whole entire
um place oh this is nice
this is really nice oh look it's so cozy
let me uh let me cook some meat in here
oh wow
oh wow that feels good oh wow yeah you
know what
i can cook meat here i can cook meat
here i can cook meat wherever i want
because it's my house
i can sleep while it cooks you all don't
understand
i don't get the respect i deserve as a
minecraft
bedroom all right i'm eating bread now
by the way
i've been playing i've been playing
minecraft with marzia and she doesn't
like me killing the animals
so i have to look into how you uh
how you get food without murdering
catholics
and i realized i came to conclusion
you can actually just make bread
[Applause]
[Music]
look how beautiful this is look at
gorgeous dude my god
oh that reminds me i downloaded this
like high resolution texture pack i
downloaded it ages ago
i want to show you it's kind of cool
actually yeah now it looks kind of cool
look at the grass dude if i send you
this would you be like is that minecraft
look at that grass look at that sand
dude
oh my god gorgeous oh so pretty ugh
look at the wheat bro amazing
it only really looks good if you zoom in
but
i'm not gonna play with this because i i
feel like it loses the the soul of
minecraft a little bit
but it's still kind of cool dude look at
the hardwood floor i love it
that's so cool this is sick look at the
tree trunks my dude
and then you have a torch that ruins it
but
look at the floor oh how does a furnace
house look
oh the [ __ ] is this
oh okay
[Music]
look at the tree how does it look like
in hd
like an actual bee come out
come out that's so weird it's all blocky
i'll turn it up just thought that was
cool you know
for today i want to go back to the
nether because people say i'm not brave
enough and i'm a chicken
and that's what a coward is i'm not
coward okay uh
now that i have breda's food so
delicious
look i won't have to kill you anymore
that's right
look i made it bigger by the way they
have been complaining that there's not
enough space but look there's
there's plenty of there's plenty of
space right guys
this guy does not give a [ __ ] does he
iron cow all right here you go there you
go
i fill in a given christmas gift the
mood no more killing
look how much space there is back there
dude amazing i don't get what the whole
fuzz is you know
so yeah i'm level 24. i have a mending
book that i had forever and i want to
put that on a pickaxe
and i want to get rods yeah so we're
going to go into the nether
and try and level up i can make legs
that's it that's all i can make [ __ ]
legs
amazing cool i'm poor
oh no don't look at me i'm so poor
as you can see has made a bunch of honey
so what i'm gonna do is i'm just gonna
get it
joke you thought i would fall for that
you think i'm not a minecraft veteran
i didn't realize i had that all right
don't kill me
i'm just gonna cook you all right so you
calm down and now
yeah hey sorry i didn't steal anything
look how happy he is oh my god he's so
happy you can you can tell
there's pure joy in those eyes staring
blankly into nowhere
that's happiness right there he is so
happy there's no
i'm so glad
[Laughter]
yeah those yellow boots who doesn't love
them
here we go see ya jurgen
take care of cows if i don't make
make it back i made it a little safer
i have golden boots can't touch me
ah come on are you serious why
why do they keep coming on my bridge you
got no business what do i do
i run past them or do i kill them hmm
what if i put a oh yeah i can put water
in there
do i push them off oh [ __ ]
no oh
no
oh
oh that's a problem oh god go get it get
up get up get it if i could fall i could
follow
oh jesus christ oh i hate this biome i
thought a ton i thought
i gotta make it oh oh
all right new strat bridge number two
coming right
up good thing i brought a ton of stone
that's right i don't i don't really like
that bridge
[Music]
[Laughter]
go away this is my maid i'm way
there
what do i do
i build my way back there and then build
my way back to the bridge
yeah let's do that and then i'll murder
the child
see i don't understand why the pigs
keeps attacking me i really don't
all right safe here oh look at this
idiot you're gonna die you're so dead
you're gonna die you're gonna die
can you push me up that's the real
question
let's be responsible here i ain't taking
no chances anymore
i got a pet b now i got a reason to live
can you help can you help all right i'm
not
i'm not afraid of a child come on
are you so you're so dead run to mommy
run to mommy
run to mommy run to mommy run to mommy
run to mommy
you didn't see nothing here have a bed
oh another child run your little fools
run run
oh you're sad come back yeah
oh all right well that cooks i'll kill
the child
ah a child is not gonna kill me yeah
run idiot
[Music]
all right let's keep going this is going
great
are they coming from there it closes up
make sure the bridge is safe i spend so
much time making it safe
it's clearly not safe i'm gonna lose it
dude
uh yeah i don't know why i'm doing this
just felt appropriate oh mom tastes so
good
mmm i love pork they could drop down
from there
on my bridge and that's illegal
i built this bridge i deserve it oh look
at that that's
phenomenal all right so what i'm gonna
do and i came up with this genius plan
on my own
because i'm a minecraft veteran what
we're gonna do is we're gonna dig
underneath them
this is actually what the vikings used
to do a lot of people don't know this
they dug tunnels and then they strike
their knees
all right we're taking it careful okay
there we go
strike their knees damn they hit hard
yes right away dude oh they can't hit me
here this is genius
so we're under the spawn now does that
mean it can spawn in here i should
probably
place this is why i brought these
nope yes oh
i'm i'm insane i know the plan
is working swimmingly the knees
belong to me
no thanks give me your knees bro
oh that was sexy oh
ow stop i gotta back up
shoot
[Music]
nice oh another one sweet i mean this is
kind
of working but i'm thinking more like
for the future
nope how many do i have i have three
that means i have five
is that enough hold up let me go back
if you're nervous right now just know
that you're the only one
a ton of slabs
let's cover it up [ __ ] there's a ton of
them i think they
keep spawning
oh he dropped one damn it this is how
the pros do it
it i don't think so dude my little my
little s
you gotta hit in here brush mine craft
it's a game
oh god don't come in here just go leave
please
i have to shoot now shoot
i'm just doing the half slabs for those
of you noobs
so they don't spawn in my tunnel i know
you're super confused by my delight
oh my god dude i have six of them i
think i'm good i think i'm good
cool yeah no one ever call me coward
again ooh
man this is really reminiscent of my old
playthrough i remember trying to get to
level 30.
27 baby oh yeah is the bridge shape
you know i don't have to do this but
you're
it's too funny i don't know i'm not a
psychopath
they are all right it shouldn't be on my
bridge i told them gotta pay the
the pie toll what the hell is that oh
yeah
don't come near me see they're afraid
now i asserted dominance
no one dares go brian bridge near
english is my second language thank you
are they standing on top of each other
that's so cute what
i love that again i don't understand how
you can die
just don't die actually i understand now
the kiddie pool
you gotta watch out for the kiddie pool
why fine this is mine
it's so dumb i should just set up these
that's actually kind of smart oh little
lost baby
looking for their mama watch out while
you go there let you my darling
[Music]
oh no he did oh no
oh that's so sad
i just realized no we're cool we're cool
are we cool he's just humping the wall
that's fine
people say that i don't play adventures
you probably just want me to die
i've been painted all right come on
level 20 nine come on
oh we're 29 i think i should kill him
this will be my first enderman kill
uh okay let's try the ice strategy dice
hey you
oh my god that was so easy are you
serious okay nice
oh let's go
but where i i don't know home i would
like to go home
come on one more oh
that one felt good all right let's go
back in the beginning of this
series i said to you guys which episode
you think i'm gonna die at
hey if if you didn't say episode 500
you lost you lost because it's happening
level 30 baby what up oh yeah
sorry i talked too much and then
i understand disgusting but i've been
isolating for the past year i don't know
how to human anymore
hey why is he not making honey
hello hello oh lazy b
lazy look i know
i know yeah i know
i know write in comment i know i just
know
oh we got one yeah
okay nice that means next episode we can
go to the
the thing work harder
[Music]
god you know what happened to your
predecessor
i get no respect all right
all right gamers this is what we're
going to do
oh yeah i need an anvil i don't know how
i forgot everything
everything minecraft related i need mad
i don't think i have enough
[ __ ] it's fine
we're gonna start off with this come on
give me something good
come on come on efficiency
fine is that it that's it
okay this is fault somehow
damn it's fast yeah vitamin d
oh honey time you did good my man
i'm not sure what i do with the honey
but it's honey time oh yeah
oh what a good slice what a good boy
i just realized he can escape oh my god
he didn't he didn't leave that means he
loves it here
thank you thank you all right let me
just go to my
little house oh
this oh my god there's two of them oh
yeah fight each other now
excuse me while i just cook hey that's
illegal
how dare they enter my house i don't
understand how they could even make it
in here
that's ridiculous we're running at 100
efficiency right now
what can i say i'm a man of house ovens
oh you play minecraft oh where you have
furnace house oh
oh you know oh okay now we can make a
anvil
yeah yeah yeah this took way too long
hold up do i have to do this
yep yeah
wait i can't yeah
damn they're expensive all right you go
here
and boom
boom boom
nice all right we're getting there
hell yeah i want to do something really
comfy at the end of this episode
thanks for supporting this series so far
by the way i love reading all the
comments
boom should i enchant the fishing rod on
breaking
uh all right fine
if i break this will it come out because
i want it to come out no
don't hurt me you'll die you'll die if
you hurt
[Music]
oh don't be mad at me don't be mad don't
die don't die
don't die i know you're angry i know
you're angry do not hurt me
you can't hurt me you use a wig [ __ ]
oh my gosh i need that
nice yeah we gonna do huh all right i'm
gonna let you cool down for him
oh there we go we homies now bruh
all right nice there we go
where'd he go go back
look at him he's got a little hat look
how cute he's just got his little hat on
oh you're adorable
all right let's leave him alone i want
to do some quick fishing some morning
fishing
how are the cows here again oh they love
it in here
oh love it look
yeah look at that oh i'm so glad you
guys like your new barn
that makes me happy oh
all right if you come this way i got
this little port set up
boom oh dude look at this
this is minecraft right here how do i
how do i play fish why am i not getting
anything
oh there we go there we go
[Music]
oh my first fish it's a puffer fish
look at this you're my new companion
i'll keep you in my off hand
another one all right oh yeah this is a
bit boring i just wanted to
take this time to say a huge thanks to
everyone for supporting the sears
supporting the channel it's been an
amazing year i had so much fun
and i keep getting puffer fishies thanks
for watching another one i'll see you in
the next year
with another minecraft episode brofist